Il y a un sujet dont tout le monde parle entre amis, entre collègues, devant la machine à café...
C'est les mots de passe.
Faux !
Je ne peux pas te laisser dire ça Alan.
Tu as tout faux, on en parle jamais et pour cause, c'est secret les mots de passe.
Je sais Steven, c'était de l'ironie.
Mais bien sûr.
Tu me fais honte Alan.
Tu ne connais rien sur rien, tu n'es vraiment pas digne de reprendre la société de papa.
Alors là je peux te dire que j'en connais un rayon sur les mots de passe, alors ne me cherche pas.
Très bien.
Le premier qui n'aura plus rien à dire de pertinent sur les mots de passe
ne reprendra pas la société de papa.
Défi relevé.
Tu ne me fais pas peur Steven.
Et là ?
Non plus.
Je prends la main.
Je t'en prie.
Quel idiot, il n'y a qu'une seule chose à dire sur les mots de passe...
En prenant la main, je gagne forcément.
C'est marrant, les mots de passe sont souvent en rapport avec la personne qu'on aime.
Par exemple, Barbara04 ou Kili92.
Bien observé.
Il est foutu.
Comme mot de passe,
il y a aussi celui créé pour un compte il y a trois ans et qu'on retrouve plus.
Hein ?!
On essaie tous les différents mots de passe qu'on a pu avoir,
on finit par cliquer sur mot de passe oublié...
Et là, ça nous le renvoie sur un vieux mail dont on a plus le mot de passe non plus.
Game over Alan.
Ce n'est pas drôle, tu viens de faire une croix sur la société de papa.
Mais on a jamais dit qu'il fallait que ce soit marrant.
Merde !
Soit, c'est à toi.
Non c'est à toi.
Merde ! Si jamais je ne parle plus peut-être qu'il ne s'apercevra de rien.
Tu n'as plus rien à dire ?
Merde !
Non c'est faux, j'ai encore plein de trucs en stock.
Je t'écoute.
As-tu souvent...
As-tu remarqué que souvent...
Y a un truc que tout le monde fait Alan.
C'est...
Le mot de passe commun.
Celui qu'on partage avec ses potes ou sa copine...
Pour Spotify ou Netflix.
Et qui est totalement différent de notre mot de passe Facebook.
Ou Snapchat.
C'est bien formulé.
J'ai eu très très chaud, mais là, il est cuit.
Il y a aussi un autre truc de marrant avec les mots de passe...
Non c'est impossible, il n'y a plus rien à dire !
C'est leur évolution.
A l'époque on pouvait simplement écrire un mot...
Du type saucisse...
Et aujourd'hui on nous demande d'ajouter une majuscule, des chiffres...
Qu'est ce que ce sera ensuite ? Des émojis ?
Ce n'est pas du tout pertinent Alan.
Tu penses que cette expérience est universelle, mais elle ne l'est pas.
C'est vrai Steven ?
A part toi, tout le monde a tout de suite pensé à mettre des majuscules et des chiffres.
Moi même mon mot de passe c'est x5Cgu8Li...
Et ce... depuis mon tout premier skyblog.
J'étais persuadé que cette expérience était universelle.
La partie est terminée Alan.
Ne dites-plus un mot !
Docteur Miles !
Oui, lui-même.
En tant que proche incontesté de cette famille, je me dois de rétablir la vérité.
Son mot de passe est bien x5Cgu8Li, mais il est le seul à avoir eu directement ce type de mot de passe.
Voilà la vérité: il l'a tapé sans faire exprès... alors qu'il tombait dans les escaliers !
C'est vrai ?
Non il ment !
Depuis cet évènement il a gardé un fort traumatisme.
Tu n'as jamais remarqué qu'il ne prend jamais les escaliers ?
Mais oui !
Maintenant que j'y pense, c'est vrai qu'il préfère toujours escalader les façades.
Tout s'explique !
Qui de Alan ou de Steven reprendra l'entreprise familiale ?
Je sais pas.
J'suis comme vous.